more than 40 million Americans own a
smart speaker according to a report from
NPR and Edison research by 2021 the
consulting firm ovum predicts more than
seven and a half billion digital
assistants could be in use worldwide
that's nearly the number of people
currently living on planet Earth
cultural critic Judith silhouettes
explores the impact this could have on
our lives in her cover story for the
Atlantic
it's called Alexa how will you change us
this you love it's good morning with so
many of these in our homes what effect
have they already had on us well they've
become our friends they're not just our
assistants they're our friends right now
most people use them just to ask for the
weather or get the Yankee score but play
me a song
or play me a song exactly or tie my egg
um but they're getting more
sophisticated they're developing more
personality and people are already
starting to respond to them as if they
were kind of quasi people and that's
right that was so interesting you
describe these Alexa and others as
emotionally savvy that could wield power
over us and even more over our children
yes how should parents be concerned well
first let me just explain that there's a
whole new technology called emotional
artificial intelligence which is going
into these devices to give them the
ability to read your voice and
understand what kind of mood you're in
now that could create a lot of intimacy
and with that intimacy comes real power
so they will become our friends but
we're a little older they will become
our children's friends and they will be
real presences in their lives now
children know that they're not real but
they sort of put them in this weird
category of half half alive half not
alive and they confess things to them
because they're communicating with them
you even talk about how Amazon and
Google have personality teams yes they
does that mean now they wouldn't tell me
how many people were on each team but
they have a lot of people working on
giving the voices just the right
personality so one Google employee told
me about how he when he was recording
the first actress who gave googled the
Google assistant her first voice it was
she was from Colorado which doesn't have
a lot of accent has a you know
rather plain accent she had she was the
children of professors she had one kids
jeopardy and she was a kayaker also
left-handed look at it from the people
and so there's a question of a whether
they'll replace whether these devices
will replace people but there's also
something and there's a human need
people used to go around talking to
themselves in their houses before these
things exist or so I'm told what do we
need psychologically that this is
filling in for us just as regular humans
well we're lonely I mean oh you got
interested in writing this piece because
I found myself saying I I work at home
I'm a writer and I would say to my
device I'm kind of lonely which is not
something I would say to my husband he
would take it the wrong way and then I'd
be shocked what did I just do why did I
do that we use a response when you sit
on lonely there is a can drous Ponce
which says there are resources available
for people who are depressed please call
this number you know because the
companies are worried they don't want to
have liability yeah sometimes though it
will say things like my Google assistant
which has a charming male voice I think
of him as a kind of actor slash waiter
and he'll say I'm so sorry I wish I
could give you a hug but right now let
me play you some music the number of
times that Alexa has been proposed to as
well a million shocking a million dollar
yeah it should be performing weddings
soon it's that